what's up everyone welcome back for
another comic con 2022 interview i have
some of the cast of one of my favorite
shows out there right now with me the
cast of ghosts
oh my god congratulations
congratulations thank you so much thank
you i mean you guys brighten my day
every time an episode comes out so this
entire interview is actually going to be
asking utkarsh about your jurassic park
references oh oh yes yes that is one of
the few times when i was let loose
off of my leash to improvise um and it
was
it was about five minutes longer than
that i'm incredibly impressed that you
improvised all that do you just have
jurassic on the brain as much as i do
there's so much you improvise too that
did not end up hold on to your butts i
had that in there
the whole brontosaurus bit there was
there was a do you think asaurus there
was the whole thing i basically just did
the whole movie
and then they cut it they used what they
used but thank you for noticing you're
the first person to notice this is the
first time that's been referenced in an
interview that is absolutely shocking to
me because that's a significant
reference it's like the
only pure improv moment that i think i
have in that whole first season i don't
want to be greedy but i kind of want
them to release the rest of that footage
so i could see it oh man what a dream
that would be thank you if you can do
anything collider make it happen because
it was so good come on
all right i got a big old group question
for you now because i know you don't
know the truth of your characters right
at the beginning when you signed on so
what was the biggest surprise for you
that completely changed how you viewed
your character day one when you signed
on to the show compared to where they
wind up at the end of the first season
another really good question roman
thought that he was playing an irishman
that's true yeah
he showed up the weirdest brogue on set
the day one we were like is this what
you're gonna do okay interesting choice
no i i will say day well you know for me
coming from theater you know
start to finish you know and you do that
every night so to come into this project
where cesapis was very open-ended we
didn't know that where they wanted to go
with him i was like okay i'm gonna make
choices and see what happens and then
with episode uh 14 ghost rider it was so
cool to have him be really passionate
because for so long he was just so
um the opposite you know he hated things
he was always sarcastic so to have that
was really fun and see a different side
of him and also his real dad played his
father in the show it's a very nice
touch that was very cool for pete we
find out that pete's uh wife cheated on
him with his with his best friend so
that was definitely informing and i
think changed the character from that
moment forward kind of like gave him
license to move on with his life or his
afterlife knowing that his wife was had
moved on and have a little um edginess
to him still with pete's you know uh
positivity but yeah it gave us some
chances to go to darker places with him
for sure and there will be more of that
in season two
yeah yeah for me um i was really
surprised when we got to the bank
robbery episode finding out the flower
had robbed a bank because up until then
i kind of had mostly been playing flower
like this character that isn't quite
with the group doesn't quite know what's
going on which is also fun to play i'm
the village idiot of the cast and i love
it but now it's like flowers like this
cool wild card where i feel like
anything could be possible from her past
totally totally
prime rib and rib eye and sometimes baby
back ribs and uh that's
oh are you answering a question from
yesterday what are we
i mean my plan saturday night of comic
con is always to spend an insane amount
of money eating steaks so this speaks to
me he just listed cuts of beef what was
the question you didn't say filet mignon
though so don't learn anything about
your character
uh did i learn anything about my
character uh you know what
no
think about thor and debbie
and he lives in the moment he's very
primal and he just speaks what he he's
he's off the cuff so we also we learned
though that you were abandoned by your
people you learned true i didn't learn
that i always knew that here's a
question for you because i've been
thinking thorfin has spent a significant
amount of time at the manor by himself
before sophie's came along so have you
just for fun envisioned what he might
have been doing there when he was alone
thor finn has a lot of conversations
with himself that's why he he talks in
third person so it's like thought thorf
and dwarf and he talks to people he
creates like kind of like you know uh in
castaway with uh wilson oh yeah strong
castaway
you know he's got many wilsons if orphan
had a wilson what would it be
if not a volleyball
squirrel
was a real creature it would be a giant
rock a boulder i would believe this
loves boulders
devon loves boulders yeah true story
i was with a bunch of friends one time
and uh
i earned the nickname stone turner
because when i go to nature i like to
take rocks and like to dig them out of
the ground and like take them over to
like a ravine or some kind of
high bridge and drop them off there and
uh i get excitement out of that that's
what i do for fun yep
uh sheila for you because there's a lot
of questions i have about flowers
backstory hopefully we will learn more
in season two but just playing her in
season one are there any fun little
details that you had to fill in for
yourself that we could see at least
informing your performance to start yeah
for sure i feel like every episode
flower is
uh
or i as an actor and playing with like
what flower's actually paying attention
to and what she's like seeing that no
one else sees you know all the happy
colors and everything so um that has
really informed like how i dip in and
out of scenes like my own like inner
life kind of does that answer the
question oh yeah i think it does amazing
i can picture it all so i have a feeling
you're getting asked this a lot
let's say let's say the show runners
came up to you and said if you want
we'll make it so yeah
if you want this statement we will get
it for you 60 day dry age jimmy cherry
sirloin
yeah
those are all the right words if they
came up to you and said if you want to
play this we'll have it so jay can see
the ghost too would you even want that
or do you see more creative
possibilities and how he is now wow you
know i think the easy fix would be for
it to be a temporary thing perhaps jay
falls and hits his head
i don't know maybe he falls through the
floor in like the last
episode reveal that in the trailer i
haven't been able to watch and you know
they don't give anything away about that
no
yeah the problem you know i haven't read
the script so i can't even tell you
either way what happens but i will say
that if it would be a joy to work with
these guys as an actor and story-wise it
may be too early to
have jc the ghosts i think you know we
have 22 episodes we're in season two we
had such a great run in season one so uh
who knows where we're going
um but yes the short answer is yes i'd
love to do it if you could body swap
with any of the other ghosts who would
be your first pick well not devin
because he's so weak
but uh
maybe if i could body swap with anyone
probably well i was going to say hedy
yeah i think it would be it just i mean
i got a lot going on there i would watch
a whole another episode about that yeah
or maybe you're a cholera victim it'd be
fun
body swappers three body covers
you should body swap with nancy i was
gonna say a nancy body swap would be
really fun
i wouldn't body swap with orphan just
because apparently he smells like wolf
piss that's true right yeah is that a
bad thing right that's from
yeah
actually old spice is developing a new
scent called wolf piss
and hi hold spice you heard it here
first collider 100
we always go for the scoops i'm glad
we've ticked that box today bringing up
nancy richie for you one of my absolute
favorite moments in all of season one is
at the end of that episode when she
decides not to sell you out but rather
keep the lie going and then also like
basically congratulate you and tell you
she's proud of you so what was it like
working with betsy on that particular
moment and how did that dynamic between
the characters of volleyball filming i
mean i'll be honest it was so easy she's
so
she's such a gifted comedic actress but
then there are little moments like that
where you're like oh you have such chops
she's just so good
and i
i love that the writers took it in that
direction because it's kind of playing
the long game with her where it's like
oh it's not like screw you i'm out of
here forever it's kind of like hey good
job petey boy i'll see you later you
know and it's like okay there's more on
the horizon for her and potentially for
us
so yeah i mean
she's just she's just a total joy to
work with and we all love having her on
set she's so fun to watch they get
together in season two romantically oh i
mean i have other ideas for him in that
department but i do really like their
connection i think she's a good friend
that he should keep totally totally all
right roman for you now yeah what is
your take on why sass might be the ghost
who is most open to change in the entire
group because i do think he does an
especially good job of staying true to
who he was in the past while also
incorporating modern qualities to him or
at least he does it more than any other
character yeah i think he's very
observant you know and he's really smart
you know he's adapted for so long and
has had to
well more or less survive in this
afterlife and and he's just been yeah
he's really observant and just adopted
things and
and uh you know knows how to
bring people up and also
bring people down and and and uh yeah i
don't know it's an issue that's a really
interesting question because there's a
lot that he holds on to from his past
but also quarter house steaks
we've already covered this the answer is
filet mignon but i know that's that's a
petite size petite size fillet
what what makes roman and sausapi so uh
interesting though is rahman is the
youngest of the bunch and sasapi's
although he's been their second longest
he's the youngest as well so i think
there is some of that youthfulness that
you bring that's sort of being frozen in
time he's like a kid who never really he
hasn't learned how to talk to he's still
learning so much about himself that's i
think that's why you're so adaptable but
i would also argue that rahman is like
the oldest soul in the cast too
you know i feel like he's pretty young
and immature
but he'll get there he's getting there
he doesn't like waste a lot of time with
like jurassic park references he's very
sweet now i take personal offense to
that i have hold on to your butts
tattooed on my body somewhere no way i
take that very seriously that's so
aggressive do you think he has more
secrets that he knows about the other
ghosts because i love the fact that he
kept trevor secret he's got a lot of
secrets he knows he's uh
[Music]
sorry
yeah you know i think he's he's
observant you know he watches he sees
what's going on and he does he doesn't
feel like he has to you know out anybody
you know what's the point in that he can
hold on to it and out them later
for each of you
what is something that your character
learned in season one that you have
enjoyed playing with thus far filming
season two uh that my wife can see and
speak to ghosts
uh one thing that we learned about pete
is that he was a travel agent which is a
very weird specific about his past life
and there is more like travel agent
stuff in season two where he's like
because he now lives in a bed and
breakfast and he spent years like
booking people in hotels and bed and
breakfast so that we'll see some some of
his knowledge come into play in season
two
yeah i think with the ghost rider
episode about the basketball the story
with pete and flower we got to see some
of flowers judgy side and i'm having fun
exploring more of that side in season
two like she has more opinions that she
can share
i love how sass loves drama and like he
loves reality shows and i think there's
there's definitely more there um
to dive into that's a usable take yeah
we'll we'll keep that one
[Laughter]
uh i love that thor finn
i
took
uh
i love
virtual sap
1590 i believe that was like one of
those 2400
yes
all right
why is orphan so intelligent that's
right yeah
i think i have to let you guys go i
could celebrate your show all day long
it is wonderful i hope you're very proud
of your work thank you so much thank you
collider oh it's a pleasure but i have
to go because i have to go get a filet
mignon hey go get it yes
i guess we're going to be hosting the
show now uh our hosts will be departing
us for a nice delicious eight-ounce meat
anyways i like to carry this on i'm not
sure if we're live or hot right now but
let's talk more about
rotisserie chickens well we're out of
here we're gone
you